i know that in your country it's a big
deal right now that prince philip has
passed away
and i believe you performed for prince
philip once didn't you
yes i did actually perform i did the
royal variety performance i don't know
who was booking that event
on what they were anticipating i do
remember
making some jokes that were you know
saucy as you might imagine and
subsequently mining
that territory in a way that scarcely
seems appropriate
while it's curious here because some
people are obviously deeply in mourning
but also the bbc received the highest
number of complaints
ever uh because the coverage was so
expansive of the funeral
and the sort of general mourning around
prince philip
it's interesting isn't it to consider
what the future of the monarchy
might be in the light of the
you know the senior generation
presumably
reaching their mortal conclusions look
for me conan you've got to be kind of
cautious like this because i
even though this is primarily broadcast
in america and very few people watch it
there
if on the internet
if on the internet i was just saying it
is something insensitive
right about a recently deceased royal i
know what it's like to be
dragged into that quagmire so i will say
like it's
an interesting and transitional time for
all of us and the death of any person is
a
a very very sad event but kind of it's
um i suppose it's revealing it's
revealing that this is
increasingly i suppose a place a world
of cultural
division where the likes of you and i
conan
can surely bring about union in our own
ways
though for caucasians we may be at the
opposite end
of the melatonin scale we share more
surely london divides us yes i think we
are very similar yes
you have uh beautiful uh olive skin
uh dark piercing eyes um thank you
you are as i said before uh
a um an untamed
panther uh i am very uh
pale many people think that i'm ill
and um i have very little uh
to recommend me uh in the sensual realm
but i still think that you and i um are
very much alike
we're both questing comedians looking
for truth don't you think
i see you as a powerful lord of mischief
and misrule a mercurially minded man
able to skip between subject subjects
and access
realms that are it takes a lot to like
what is comedy really other than the
acknowledgement that this whole thing is
a divine play the whole thing is silly
that we take ourselves seriously we take
the world seriously and
sooner or later someone has to point out
that this whole thing is absolute
nonsense
it's madness it's madness and that's why
you
uh are being interviewed on what's still
a nationally broadcast television show
in the american
empire the richest country most powerful
country in the world
um and you are lying in bed uh wearing
what appears to be
a free robe that you got in first class
on an airplane
[Laughter]
never to re-wear any of those
first-class pajamas
i leave them there on the plane i wear
once
and i move along it's the only area of
my promiscuity that i've allowed to
remain
is with first-class pajamas
elsewhere i am a monogamous and stoic
sometimes almost celibate man living in
honor and
integrity here yes may i may
wield a crystal wand what is that what
is why do you have a crystal wine
well who doesn't have a crystal wand
about their person in this day and age
these are challenging times you leave
your house without a crystal wand you're
in jeopardy my man
okay okay
let me i only use it for magic it's a
gift actually from the great danny
harrison
oh son of a great former beatle george
harrison wonderful man
yes i love i love danny he's a good man
a very good man
he's a beautiful person do you think
that there's a visual subtext to this
that's all i would say
all i'm gonna say is i think candle
maybe um
i see nothing sexual about it at all
that's right it's
just a crystal tip wand of magic and
love and if you can think of another
context for that then it's your problem
exactly then you've got a dirty dirty
mind